hello everyone i'm back again for
another video um after yesterday my life
expectancy is probably now a few days
shorter and i also have a pretty
terrible sunburn won't even tell you
guys where but it's not good so with all
that in mind um let's uh try and
overlook the events of yesterday and get
into another video i think just to give
you guys an update on the general state
of the channel what i'm probably going
to do is make more conceptual videos
until i think june 1st because that's
about when i get back to my actual home
home where i have a good camera and then
at that point what i'll actually start
doing is start making um you know
interview prep videos where i actually
go through practice problems and go
ahead and try and solve those in a way
that is a bit more you know palatable
and
deep than what i hope other channels
have been doing okay so let's get into
this one all right so hopefully this
video is going to be relatively quick
and it's all going to be on the
following three topics which are going
to be polling websockets and server side
events so if you haven't heard of these
before they all basically fall under the
category of real time updates in a lot
of systems design interview questions
you're going to encounter a bunch of
applications that are going to need you
to be sending real-time updates to a
client in one form or another that
includes things like chat applications
like messenger or whatsapp
ride-sharing applications like uber
because you kind of have to know where
your driver is at at all times and so
generally speaking we have this need to
be able to kind of propagate all of
these updates from you know the server
which is actually holding the state or
perhaps the database but the server is
pulling from it and then going ahead and
propagating that to our actual end user
device which is either going to be a
smartphone or a laptop or something like
that so anyway we have a few options of
doing this and although generally
there's probably a better solution for
this answer it's important that we
understand why that's the best solution
and kind of the differences between the
options that we have here
okay so first off we have polling this
is kind of the naive implementation so
as we know
there's something called making http
requests and http request is basically
anytime you're going to go ahead and
from your client device
make any request to a server so that
request could be to get information or
to give it new information to put into a
database
so anyway polling is basically saying
i'm going to make a get request to the
server every x amount of seconds so you
know every five seconds you know tell me
if this baddie on instagram dm me back
guess what she didn't i'm gonna be
sitting there all day waiting
obviously this is not good because if we
have a ton of smartphones all polling
one server that is going to overload
them especially if there's no new
information
it's just going to be a waste of compute
and we obviously don't want to be doing
that
so kind of the next iteration of the
strategy of getting real-time
updates was going to be long polling
so as opposed to the typical polling
which just goes ahead and basically
hammers your server every few seconds
long polling makes an http request in
the same exact way that polling does
however what the server basically will
go ahead and do is say if i have new
information i'm going to return it and
if i don't have information i'm going to
basically store your request on
the server for a little bit
and if at some point new information
comes in i'm going to go ahead and
respond to you so in this way the client
can basically make an http request and
then not hear back for a decent amount
of time once it does hear back the
client is then going to go ahead and
kill that http connection it had made
with the cervix now it has the
information and if it wants more
information as one often tends to do in
these types of applications because it
tends to be a repeat process it's going
to establish another long poll
okay so what are the pros and cons of
this well the pros are that this is
pretty easy to implement because you're
basically just issuing a get request
as a long poll and most servers have
support for this so
that's pretty well taken care of that
being said it also has a few cons
the biggest thing is that it's only one
directional if you want to go ahead and
get that information from the server to
the client then send more information
back you have to actually issue a
separate http request which really isn't
a huge deal but it's just something to
keep in mind
another thing is that you are probably
going to be putting a lot of excess load
on the server why is that well every
single time you have to re-establish a
new http connection via along polling
you are effectively taking up some
resources on the server to do so and so
as a result by kind of killing and then
reestablishing these connections
this is a less efficient process than
some of the other alternatives that
we'll see afterwards and then finally if
you are long polling and you have a
couple of browser tabs open at once what
may happen is that those two tabs might
be you know doubly getting the
information and that's either
inefficient or it could lead to race
conditions where you're getting
information out of order so there's
something to keep in mind there
okay moving on we have websockets so
websockets unlike long polling are a
fully bidirectional connection between
the client and server you basically go
ahead and establish a typical http
connection which then gets upgraded to a
websocket connection and from there you
can send information both from client to
server and also server to client so this
has a few pros and cons and we're going
to go through all of them keep in mind
another thing i should probably mention
is that websockets are each kind of
corresponding to a port on the server so
server can hold about 65 000 web sockets
at one time because that's about how
many free ports there are
so just keep that in mind if it ever
comes up in an interview so anyway let's
go through pros the pros are that you
have bidirectional communication which
means i don't need to be making new http
requests to go ahead and serve content
back to my server this is really great
for something like a chat app where
you're both going to be writing messages
and reading messages and so obviously if
you want that by bi-directional
communication
websockets are really nice for you
additionally websockets do something
cool where once you establish that
additional websocket request with a
certain amount of headers the headers
are not going to be sent again on every
single message so this lowers the
network overhead that you're actually
going to be have
that you're actually going to be having
when messages are sent both from client
to server and server back to the client
that being said there are a few cons
here as well first of all there's lower
support for web sockets on older
browsers
obviously that being said though as you
know they become more mature of a
technology
that kind of becomes less and less of an
issue
another thing is that keeping all of
these persistent connections with
servers
may be overkill for infrequent data
changes for example
instead of like facebook messenger what
if i was running a dashboard and i knew
that information was probably only going
to be coming in every 30 minutes it
would probably be overkill if i had all
of my client devices
keeping a persistent connection with our
server as opposed to just using a
polling once every 30 minutes that would
probably be better in that case
another issue which is a bit more niche
but i've come across it and some of the
reading that i've done on this topic is
the thundering herd problem and this is
kind of basically saying that imagine we
have you know
who knows like um 500 000 websocket
connections and those are spread across
a bunch of application servers and then
one of those application servers were to
go down
well now we have to go ahead and start
rerouting all of our websocket
connections to different application
servers obviously trying to balance them
relatively consistently but the issue is
since there's a decent amount of
overhead and actually establishing these
websocket connections
we can end up basically
you know hammering our servers and
creating all of these initializations
for websockets and as a result they can
either you know take our servers down or
just respond failures on trying to
initialize all these websocket
connections and it could lead to
cascading failures
this this doesn't happen with long
polling for example because you know if
you have a load balancer up between all
of your application services and long
polling is basically just saying just
route my request to one of the back ends
the load balancer is going to do that
routing automatically for you you don't
have to kind of
manually reroute everything like you
might in a websocket configuration and
that can kind of lead to issues and
additional complexity
okay finally we have server sent events
service sent events basically
going back web sockets were two
directional service and events going
back are now one directional only from
servers to clients and what you do is
the client goes ahead and registers for
events from server
this is really useful for things where
basically you only have one directional
communication but you just need it in
real time so stock ticker updates you
know news feed updates from facebook or
twitter
notifications all can be useful with um
server sent events
so basically here um unlike long polling
server sent events actually you know
also keeps a persistent connection and
that's similar to web sockets but in
addition to the functionality of web
sockets as far as persistent connection
goes um server sent events will actually
handle uh re-establishing you know
closed connections if they were to go
down for some reason so you know it just
takes a little bit of complexity away
from the application as opposed to
having to use something like a heartbeat
to determine if a websocket connection
is down and then manually trying to
re-establish it
that being said there are some cons the
main one being that it's only single
directional communication
if you want to use server side events
and then additionally send information
back to the server you would have to use
separate http requests and then
additionally like websockets a lot of
concurrent connections that are
redundant if there aren't really many
events being sent can just be additional
load on a server if they're not needed
so basically servers and events are
pretty useful they're kind of a more
limited set of options than web hooks
but i think they also are technically
slightly lower overhead and a little bit
easier to set up so there is a case to
be made for using them
for kind of some of the examples that i
gave on this slide
that being said in conclusion
in an actual systems design interview
it's probably fine to just go ahead and
say oh we have real-time updates i'm
just going to use websockets that being
said don't be surprised if your
interviewer then says to you well why
web sockets as opposed to i don't know
lawn polling or servicent events and
this is kind of where these topics would
come in where you can basically just go
ahead and say well i want this
bi-directional communication i like that
you're not resending all of these
headers all the time so there should be
lower overhead et cetera et cetera et
cetera
and so basically again i'm just trying
to to dive deeper into the trade-offs
both for my own knowledge and yours in
order to be able to kind of justify all
the choices that you're making when
doing a systems design interview
all right guys so like i said i kind of
gave the channel itinerary for the next
two weeks please uh subscribe to me so i
you know don't start losing faith that
people care about these videos because i
am a narcissist
and uh yeah i look forward to see you
guys in the next one